[MUSIC PLAYING]
My goal is to not actually
do any measurements
other than using pie.
So the entire thing is
going to pie based.
We get the circumference in
the exact number of pies--
give or take-- we get the
diameter in number of pies.
Divide one by the other,
we get pi.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Pi was historically rarely
calculated this way, because
it's notoriously inaccurate
to try and get--
I know, we're idiots-- it's
notoriously inaccurate to try
and calculate pi by measuring
a circle.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To get any kind of accuracy on
our final answer we have to be
as precise as we can be.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is a mild problem, because
I want to go from the
very edge of the circle.
But as you can see, I've
positioned all the pies
exactly on the line as if
they're little mini tangents.
So I'm going to have to move
these two out and then I can
start doing the diameter exactly
on the circumference
there, like that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So that's 84 and 1/3.
264 and 2/3 pies around,
we have the diameter,
is 84 and 1/3 pie.
To get pi, we just divide the
circumference by the diameter.
OK, and if we actually work out
what that is, it equals--
that's pretty good.
Pi from pies, we got 3.13834,
which is approximately 3.14.
So using pies, we've
got pi to be 3.14.
I am a very happy
man right now.
With the diameter, and if I know
that ratio, I can just
measure the diameter.
That's the easy bit
to measure.
The center point will
be my pen, and the
outside will be the chalk.
So the pies, in theory, are
a fairly consistent size.
So they're all--
yeah they're about the same.
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]